how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in Donald was a book that I wrote
called the language folks several years
ago where I was just writing about this
sapir-whorf hypothesis that languages
make you see the world in different way
and I reiterate that to a small extent
they do but it's a really small extent
that I don't think qualifies as
something that most humanists would be
interested in and so for example in
Russian they're two words for blue one
of them refers to dark blue one of them
refers to the blue that's the cap on
that bottle there is no just blue blue
word and if you do an experiment you can
show that Russians are very very very
very very slightly better than English
speakers at delineating exactly where
dark blue shades off into light blue
it's just that color it's a very tiny
difference and so that's neat in itself
but what you know if you know any
Russian what does that have to do with
Russian this and all of the experiments
come out that way and so what I worry
about with the quote unquote hoax is
that you are you are always given the
cool examples so Wow Russians see blue
in a landscape like this right here
supposedly to be Russian is to see that
somehow more vibrantly than most of us
see it and you think well wow that's
really interesting or you learned that
Japanese people because of one of the
quirks of their grammar are more
sensitive to materials than we are and
so you think well they're more sensitive
and we English speakers are kind of
these dullards and it really ends up
feeling good but there are all sorts of
crummy things you can end up saying
about people based on what is or what
isn't in their language and I won't go
through them now so we take up too much
time but you can look at any language
and based on that perspective designate
people as sexist as racist things that
are not in a language can make people
look frankly kind of dim this includes
everybody in China and so that whole
perspective that what's in the grammar
or how they cut the world up with words
makes people cool ends up also making
people seem uncool and if you don't want
the uncool which I don't think most
of us do you immediately learn these
things and you say well that that
couldn't have anything to do with what
the people are like then that has to
also go for the cool things too and so
that's why I think of these differences
as dancing upon what most of us would
find crucial but it's not that those
things aren't there but for example very
quickly Mandarin Chinese speakers have
been shown to process counterfactual tea
a tiny bit more slowly than other people
because you can't say had had been would
have in Mandarin Chinese tiny bit less
sensitive do you want to say that people
who speak Mandarin aren't as good at
processing hypothetic ality it's the
rest of us of course not we just reject
that well and same thing with the
Russians and the blues you have to we
have to be you have to be uniform better
a necessary thing that there's no
control during that you don't you can't
ever take the first that's the same
individual and induct them compulsorily
from birth into English and then take
that individual and induct them into
Mandarin Chinese and look at the
differences in their perception of the
world I mean he needs that individual to
obediently bifurcates and live their
life twice in two different and that
would be a [ __ ] experiment it's quite
hot sometimes yeah they definitely
looked at people with different amounts
experienced with English at different
times in their lives and the more
Chinese you've got the less you are good
at pressing buttons at certain times are
resolving certain elaborate little word
games you don't do them as quickly and
that's a disturbing experiment that you
kind of wish the person hadn't done
which shapes my perception and so to
speak of all of the war feein
experiments
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival at how the
light gets in aaaggghhh